will england win the world cup the world
cup or a world cup another one the qatar
2022
i'm gonna go with yes i think our
players are better than they were at the
euros
i'm gonna give it to us i think we can
do it
all right you're like i'm jermaine genus
and i'm about to answer some questions
from the sport bible audience uh so
let's have it based on their ability now
pick a five aside team from pundits
you've worked with five aside game
you've just got to be all ex-pundits who
do you want your team right now right
now
i have rio at the back can you see the
size of rio
rio's fitter now than when he was
playing
he's like he's a monster so i'd probably
go with rio at the back shay given he's
a mate of mine and he's got a massive
blockhead so nothing's going in with
sheamus
shane goal uh rio at the back coupling
midfield skullzy all day long this guy's
still a wizard still can knock it around
i'll go midfield with him actually i can
still run around and do a bit up top i
think crouchy i don't think crouching
needed to retire you know during my
whole time playing with crowd she didn't
even get one massage no treatment just
turn up and play i think he could still
play he could still do a job approaching
so i'm going to go with crouch up top
put joe cole on the bench because i
think between me and him we're going to
need to
flip-flop and joey still plays as well
like he's a sunday league player i think
so yeah
who are the best players you played with
at newcastle spurs and england
oh wow uh i caught shearer at the back
end of his career
and he was still a joke the level of
finishing
was just beyond anything i'd seen center
office didn't like playing against him
he was physical we used to hurt them and
used to like give them a nightmare
and referees used to bow to him because
that's a fact i played in games while
watch referees melt the minute shearer
shouted at them and i just think thank
god he's on my team and then spurs i
always say luke and moderate bail did
some scary things ledly was a way better
footballer than i expected him to be but
luka
modric was
beyond anything i think i'd seen during
my time at spurs who was the best player
you played with in england
gerard all right yeah
higher than schools lampard
scholars he was only there for a little
while i went through the phase of
scholzi when he was getting pushed out
onto the left wing a bit in training he
was like outrageous that's scary stuff
he was just a brilliant footballer
gerard was just different
very different he was just like no i'm
gonna be the best player every single
day he'd made you realize that he was
kind of like a better player and he did
that to most people
will england win the world cup the world
cup or a world cup another one the
guitar 2022
i'm gonna go yes
okay i'm gonna go yes i think our
players are better than they were at the
euros
yeah
i'm gonna give it to us i think we can
do it was it a hard time when you left
spurs
it was a hard time yeah for many reasons
it was a hard time the way that it was
done wasn't pretty my issue was with
kind of like andre vs bowers at the time
i just come back from watching my
achilles and at spurs they've got
fingerprint id everywhere and i put my
thumb on the thing it just went red just
went ah
and i'm like
looking at reception and they're like
got their heads down like writing in
papers i was like i try again put it on
yeah this went red so i just jumped over
the barrier and then like ledley and i
think bradford at the time came and
spoke to him with that look jay we've
spoke to the graphic and i don't know
why he's done this but he's kicked you
out dressing room and you gotta go and
get changed with the kids we've been
arguing for a few days that
you're not a bad one in the dressing
room i don't know why he's done this
blah blah blah you know considering i
spent like seven or eight years at the
football club for it to end in that way
it wasn't nice at all did vsports ever
give you a explanation no have you seen
him since no no no i haven't no i've got
no interest in seeing him
we didn't see eye to eye put it that way
who is your favorite current premier
league player to watch bernardo silva
him or phil foden are my two favorite
kind of players to watch they play the
game at a different level different
speed their intelligence is is far
beyond anything i i see out there to be
honest with you
who do you think is the best under-21
player in the premier league right now
my favorite youngster that i watch right
now is jacob ramsey who plays a villa i
love this kid so much he's got this flow
to his game that when he takes the ball
on his back foot he glides by people
that's what zidane used to do but then
when he's got that driving mentality
that's what yaya tori used to do he's
composed in deep areas on the ball he
can nick a goal he's got all these
different like facets of different
players that i look at in his game at a
very young age and think i'm not seeing
much wrong with this player he's my tip
for the player that will make it into uh
gareth southgate's squad in for the uh
world cup who was the best manager you
played under and why bobby robson was
probably the best manager i played under
you know he was literally like a father
figure to me at the time when i was 18
years old
in newcastle complete call to change for
me
um he just looked after me bobby wasn't
you know it wasn't the most when it came
to tactical things i don't remember him
obsessively being thinking he cared
about the fans and the performance and
the work rate that you put in and he was
quite happy to expose it if you didn't
and i think you wanted to you wanted to
please him you know you wanted to be
always on his good side and i think that
is what i always loved about him
who would you say are the top secrets
now if if lester are in there who's
who's dropped out well liverpool are in
there
united are in there city are in there
chelsea are in there
and leicester in the last few years i
would say arsenal fans will probably
like caught some stat now that you know
i mean because i think i ate them anyway
it's like they drain me